it's a friday pft ot usually i'm by
myself on a friday for pftot but because
chris sims found it in his heart to work
on a friday day isn't it fun to work on
a friday don't you want to work on more
fridays well i don't know if i want to
work more fridays but i like working on
a day after a lot of football games that
certainly made it better so no i'm going
to try to stay strong with my no friday
work policy but uh it was good it was he
had a fun show today it was it was a lot
of fun it was a fun show and we got some
stuff to address that we talked about
during the show some things we didn't
talk about one topic we argued about
during a break so uh let's let's get to
it i want to start with something we did
spend some time discussing but the thing
about doing a live tv and radio show
you're constrained by that clock you
have to shut up at a certain time you
got to land the plane and you got to
move on let's get back to the new replay
review for pass interference regardless
of whether you like it or not and i
don't like it the reality is it's going
to significantly change the game because
now we've got the ever present
possibility that someone's going to
throw a deep pass
and there's not going to be a flag for
past interference
and somebody's going to throw the red
challenge flag
questioning whether or not there's pass
interference a couple of minutes later
al riveron from 345 park avenue is going
to hand out
40 yards of field position last night it
was 33 yards that he gave the jets after
adam gase challenged the no call of pass
interference chris this is a huge
dynamic and i hope they understand what
it's going to do to the game yeah it is
i'm concerned just like you are there's
a lot of moving parts here
uh first off you know it's a it's a
subjective play you and i and 10 other
people in a bar could be watching the
game and seven could say you know six
could say it's past interference four
could not or vice versa whatever it may
be so then it shouldn't be that's the
thing yes okay if there's any
disagreement among those people in the
bar
it should not be overturned that
subjective judgment call should be
honored that's my concern okay it's got
to be as clear as what we saw in ram
saints before and it's got to be clear
and obvious and boom not something you
have to study or look at carefully if
you have to look at it carefully it's
not clear and obvious and that's my
concern that you have things that get
overturned that in the past when there
wasn't a flag thrown nobody thought it
was a big deal right you know oh yeah
that was kind of close but you know it's
a judgment call and we move on now all
of a sudden you've got this new
horizon of calls that you can say hey
maybe that was past interference and the
red flag comes out now wherever on
agrees that it was yeah well i mean as
far as the way it was last night you
know and i know you used the phrase like
handing out 44 yards or 40 yards or 33
yards whatever it may be hey you know
the the the the the non-call on the
field was blown last night you know
that's that's the best way i could say
it it was applied correctly in that
giants jets game last night where we saw
adam gase challenge it the guy clearly
had the the hold of the wide receiver's
wrist where he could not get another
hand up there and not just for like a
split second it was like grab grab
grab grab and he never let go of it so
he had it locked down to where the guy
never got a chance to put two hands to
try to actually catch the football so it
was a correctly applied there but i'm
with you i mean clear and obvious needs
to be the phrase of the year i'm i don't
want to see like
ticky tack or you know there was some
hand fighting by both sides and then the
guy who hand fought the last is the one
that gets called as the ball was getting
there whatever it may be those are the
things that scare me along with the pace
of the game um and you know
we'll we'll see you made a good point
about if there's a ton of pass
interference calls will they stay
with you know
spot foul right if it's 40 yards
downfield you get 40 yards will they go
to the college way with the 15 yards i
don't know but either way dbs better be
on their p's and q's this year because
yeah things are going to be analyzed
more than ever as far as
what they're doing down the field while
the ball is in the air
i think the obvious next step is that
indeed they're going to be pushing to
change past interference to a 15-yard
penalty that bubbles up from time to
time in the nfl i think that it becomes
inevitable when we look at the
consequences of our river on dropping a
flag from hundreds of miles away and
giving a team that much field position a
third of the field went to the jets last
night based upon the review and i still
believe
that the bar needs to be higher before
we're going to invade the subjective
judgment it's one thing chris to look at
the the shot of the sideline and see
whether or not the guy got two feet down
before he went out of bounds with a
catch or whether or not his knee was
down before the ball came out that's
undeniable that's objective
i still think even the grab of the wrist
there's an element of subjectivity that
comes into play here that i don't like
having the judgment made in real time
invaded and and even though you could
argue last night yeah he did grab the
wrist and hold it and maybe it was a
good decision there's going to be plenty
of these that were complaining about
while where al river on went too far i
guarantee you that's gonna happen yeah i
i think there is too well i mean
you know al al and he's got a tough job
and i know that but he has not
necessarily been the best with clear and
obvious last year was a little bit
better two years ago it was shaky so uh
it is certainly the aspect i i am gonna
look at and uh we're gonna see the more
of these penalties are called and things
and we get to flush it out i think you
know more and more problems are gonna
kind of float to the surface here's the
other thing too is this what they want
do they want you and i every monday
morning breaking down in a full segment
all of the past interference calls and
non-calls that shouldn't have been where
and and it's going to happen far more
often than not where a flag is thrown
via replay review than where a flag is
picked up because i think
it's going to be almost impossible to
have a flag picked up because if there's
any contact and they say pass
interference then it's past interference
and how do you overturn it it's going to
be these situations where there's no
call in real time and now river runs
dropping the flag and we're going to end
up talking about it a lot unless they
make that bar higher
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports